So Leute, ich bin wieder da. Ich war in Ruhe auf dem Klo und hab was gegessen.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, komm, ist schon so spät.
Wollen wir einfach Stream wieder anspielen, noch ein paar Runden Battlefield.
Kurz was anklicken.
Okay, schauen wir mal. Sollte eigentlich das Game starten.
So, dann gehen wir uns noch ein paar Runden Battlefield. Mal gucken, wie es läuft.
Mal schauen.
Machen wir mal kurz den Soundtrack aus.
Lautstärke und so sollte eigentlich alles passen.
Das habe ich das letzte Mal schon eingestellt.
Und diesmal habe ich auch geguckt, dass ich gleich die Bitrate hochgestellt habe,
dass es nicht wieder kacke ausschaut.
Erstmal eine Runde.
Bashen, Alter, bashen.
Oh, perfekt.
Wir werden gleich schon wieder krass überrannt.
Alter, wir kriegen...
OKS.
Ah, ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Lull.
Moment, ich glaube, Punkbuster hat schon mal wieder nicht gestartet.
Äh, Moment, wie startet man unter Windows?
Services, äh...
Äh...
Service?
Services...
Ja, Lull!
Alter!
Ja.
Ach, ne.
Muss man mal so starten.
Okay, Admin.
Das ist Manual.
Hä?
Der ist Automatic und der ist Manual.
Alles klar.
Seems legit.
Kek.
Kek, weh.
Kek, weh, weh, weh.
Man muss es nicht verstehen.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, jetzt geht's.
So.
Das ist übrigens auch das größte Problem,
was man hat bei Battlefield 3.
Wenn's abkackt, dann liegt das in der Regel daran,
dass ihr keinen Punkbuster installiert habt.
Das ist irgendwie...
Fail. Fragt mich nicht, was da los ist.
So.
Alter.
Ich war ganz kurz weg
und jetzt sind wir schon zweite Base am Losen, ey.
Ich fass es nicht.
Hehehe.
Nö.
Gedeist worden, ja.
Oh.
Oh, ich glaub, wir kriegen grad richtig auf den Sack, ey.
Mal gucken, ob noch ein paar Leute kommen.
Komm, dann werf jetzt noch ne Granate rein.
Alter, okay, okay.
Die Runde, die Runde ist verloren.
Okay, der Panzer hat geschossen.
Vielleicht kommen wir schnell durch.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Nice.
Oh, ne.
Aber, äh, die Runde ist, die Runde ist.
RIP.
Reingechoined und auf den Sack gekriegt, ja.
Dass es nur noch Gun-Game auf Siebertower gibt.
Da musst du den, du musst den Filter umstellen.
Ah, da ist er.
Der Fatal ist am Start.
Jetzt ist Easy Win.
Easy Win, Leute.
Easy Win.
Buitwurst 82.
Also, boah, der...
Fuck, wo ist der denn am Start?
Wo ist Buitwurst?
Ey, du musst die Suche umstellen.
Mach alles raus.
Also, alle Häkchen komplett raus.
Auch bei den Games raus.
Und dann setz mal, dass du auf Rush suchst.
Alles raus machen.
Okay, die machen jetzt Überrennungs-Stells hier gleich.
Oh, da ist der Pantsman.
Der Pantsman ist am Start.
Wie, der ist nicht tot?
Monark.
Nur noch Gun-Game?
Hä?
Das macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Hallo.
Der hatte nicht mehr viel Leben, oder?
Wir müssen, ey, wir müssen dahinter.
Wir müssen dahinter.
Die, die, die, die machen schon Legehänne.
Die machen schon Legehänne.
Bevor wir überhaupt da sind.
Ich sag's euch.
Wonka-Legehänne machen die.
Oh, was ist hier los, Alter?
Juhu.
Kann man die Matchmaking...
Welche Matchmaking-Zeit?
Du brauchst kein Matchmaking.
Du gehst einfach in den Server-Browser
und suchst den Server aus, auf dem du spielen willst.
Matchmaking.
Matchmaking ist ja sowas von 2000.
Äh, 2020.
Das Game hat sowas.
Doch, wobei, das stimmt nicht.
Die haben Matchmaking.
Das stimmt nicht, dass die kein Matchmaking haben.
Aber die brauchst kein Matchmaking.
Du gehst in den Server-Browser und suchst da was raus.
Kommst du?
Kommst du rum?
Wonka!
Juhu.
Oh, als hat er mir den Kopf geballert, ey.
Kann es der Max sein?
Der echte?
Nein.
Der ist es nicht.
Okay, wir switchen mal eine Runde auf Engineer
und machen mal hier den Objective-Player.
Massive Objective-Player.
Der Poggers Objective-Player.
By the way, die können von hier hinten kommen, Team.
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das klar ist.
Aber die kommen gleich hier durch.
Sind das Schüsse?
Oder?
Warum fliegen hier Schüsse rum?
Kann mir das mal irgendeiner erklären?
Okay, oh, huge flank, Leute.
Massive Poggers-Flank kommt jetzt.
Die Flank of Doom.
Leider habe ich die falsche Klasse für den Huge-Flank.
Ich hätte, ich hätte, ich hätte Medic bleiben sollen.
Für den Huge-Flank.
Massive Flanks.
Geflankt und verloren.
Lull.
Der Flank hat sich aber richtig gelohnt.
Massiver.
Huge Massive 500 IQ-Flank.
Oh, nee, nee, nee.
360 Battlefield 3 ertrage ich nicht mehr.
Was hatte das?
720p, wenn überhaupt.
Nee, ich glaube, ich glaube, 680p oder so was ganz Scheppes.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Werden viel 3-Stämme aus.
Halte ich, halte ich wirklich auf der 360 immer aus.
360 habe ich hier noch stehen.
Beste Konsole.
Ever.
Okay, man kann sich drüber streiten.
Der Super Nintendo war auch nice.
Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen, Xbox 360.
Ich müsste, ich müsste auch mal so eine Tierlist machen hier.
Konsole Tierlist.
Wie es der Friseur gemacht hat, das machen wir nachher noch.
Da kommt die Sony Sachen aber bei mir nicht gut weg.
Also so viel wie Cyberpunk auf der One.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Ungefähr so wie Cyberpunk auf der Xbox One aussieht, sieht Battlefield 3 auf der Xbox 360 aus.
Alter, wo spawnt uns der?
Ach so.
Dummer Spawn, dummer Spawn.
Okay, also entweder machen wir jetzt Big Brain Play links herum oder Big Brain Play rechts herum.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen Big Brain Play links herum.
In der Hoffnung, dass die Gegner es nicht checken.
Leute, ich habe ein bisschen.
What the fuck?
You had a one shot in front of smoke.
Wollt ihr mich rollen?
Wie, das war kein Kill?
Jawohl, jawohl.
Ich gehe da vorne hin, dass der Vettel rausballern kann.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Halten wir, halten wir, halten wir.
Sag mal, irgendwie spawnen Gegner vor mir und sind auf einmal wieder weg.
Ich blick dann einmal durch.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Hoffentlich gibt es Rats.
Ratsbeste.
Okay, ich muss hier durch.
Durch.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Was, was ist denn da drüben los?
Ich kann da eigentlich gar nicht mehr da sein.
Hallo, Battlefield Suppression.
Hallo.
Oh, oh, huge, huge, massive, massive Rats, massive Rats.
Exquisite Rats.
Oh, fast, fast.
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Nice.
Okay, eins muss man sagen, die Noobs sind weg.
Die Noobs sind weg.
Du hast jetzt nur noch gescheite Gegner.
Aber wir haben Buitwurst 82.
Buitwurst.
Nein, nein, lass mich in Ruhe.
Lass, lässt du mich in Ruhe?
Buitwurst.
Daneben.
Alter.
Okay, okay, es wird Zeit für only high IQ plays.
Ich sehe schon.
Also B ist auch.
Danke.
Also es dürfte eines der schwersten Bases im ganzen Spiel sein.
Geteilt mit.
Alter, ja.
Geil.
Geteilt mit Sandcrossing am Anfang B.
Ja, okay, nice.
Bonk, KS.
Was ist denn hier schon wieder los gerade?
Was ist denn hier schon wieder los?
Okay, erstmal alle den Kopf schießen.
Excellent.
Oh, late.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Ich kann dich nicht retzen da drin, Kollege.
Es geht.
Es geht nicht.
Ey, die sind, die sind, die sind, die sind ja so heiß auf uns wieder.
Okay, mal kurz vorkrieschen, dass mir das nicht so viel Damage macht.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ähm, ja, Origin.
Beste.
Auch, nice.
Ich wollte ein bisschen Skama spielen, weil die habe ich quasi so gut wie nie gespielt.
Die habe ich letztens sogar erst unlockt.
Okay.
Okay, ich, ich versuche mal.
Ich versuche mal.
Ich versuche den Big Brain Flank mal.
Aber das geht gerade nicht.
Die Skars sackt im Nahkampf.
Wow.
Ja.
Der Spicke, der ist aus dem Chat.
Nice.
Okay, wir müssen, wir müssen da von beiden Seiten reinstelzen, sonst wird das nix.
Ich spawn hinten und ich versuche nochmal reinzustelzen auf die rechte Seite.
Das muss, muss.
Wir brauchen Pressure.
Pressure von beiden Seiten.
Pressure.
Okay, sobald die Granate explodiert, gehe ich rein.
Zack.
Ihr müsst spotten, Jungs.
Spotted, spotted, spotted.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Nein.
Alter, in der Ecke steht er.
Die Noobs sind weg, Leute.
Ich sage es euch, die Noobs sind weg.
Ich brauche eine Nade.
Ich brauche eine neue Granate.
Und wir müssen von hinten gucken.
Wir können jetzt, wir können jetzt voll mit Granaten zubombardieren.
Die brauchen Granate.
Einfach Granaten.
Ein Kopf.
Leute, gebt mir eine Granate.
Refresh-Box, please.
Ich aim, ich aim den Scheiß.
Oh, fuck.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Ich aim den Kack ab hinten, dass nix kommt.
Fertig.
Easy, easy clap.
Mist.
Da ist, Alter, in dem Moment, wo ich die Nade werfe, ne.
In dem Moment, wo ich die Nade werfe, ist, kommt da, kommt da raus.
Nice.
Null.
Mesh field.
Die lassen sich, die lassen sich gut wegspray, äh, wegsprayen, die gehe ich noch.
Okay, okay.
Okay, jetzt.
Okay, wir können.
Ich glaube, wir können.
Ich glaube, das geht jetzt auf.
Hoffentlich habe ich gutes Timing.
Please.
Give, give gutes Timing.
Give gutes Timing.
Ah.
Oh, fein sein.
Füllt die sich nicht automatisch auf?
Äh.
What?
Alter Falder.
Der Rettztrain ist am Start.
Guckt's euch an.
Rettztrain, Rettztrain, Rettztrain.
So muss das sein.
So, wo ist der Fatal?
Der Fatal stellst du noch da vorne rum?
Oh, nee.
Buidwurst.
Ey, ich hatte gestern Abend so ein nices Team, ne?
Mit.
Mit auch so zwei ehemaligen Battlefield 3 Hardcore Suchtern.
Die haben sich so geschreckt, die Gegner.
Alter, wo seid ihr denn alle?
Okay, ich kann da jetzt nicht raus.
Jeder hat einen Hit drauf.
Alter, ich seh, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo der Dude überhaupt ist.
Ja, äh, ich mach mal hier.
Ich mach mal Bait.
Ey, das ist aber Wahnsinn, ne?
Bin erstaunt, wie gut du noch bist.
Dankeschön.
Ja, fehlt mir viel, unglaublich viel Übung, ja.
Aber dazu kommt, dazu kommt, mal zur Ehrenrettung der Gegner,
dass, ähm, so die richtig krassen Leute auch, glaub ich, gar nicht mehr spielen.
Was?
Okay.
Haben wir es?
Aber eins ohne Scheiß, Leute, die Noobs sind weg.
Die Noobs fliegen auch nicht bei den Heli, die Noobs sind einfach weg.
Alter.
Ey, ich, ich seh da nix.
MomKS.
What the fuck?
Das ist, das ist ja echter Wahnsinn.
Also, das ist definitiv, äh, keine Noob-Gegner.
Oh, Buidwurst ist noch da, sehr gut.
Oh, dankeschön, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, wenn der clever ist, geht der jetzt irgendwie ums Haus rum.
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal.
Wir machen jetzt Big Brain, Big Brain Play.
Only Big Brain Plays, Leute.
Da drüben ist was, da drüben war was.
What the f...
Was ist mit dem Gegner los da?
Eigentlich will ich ins Haus.
Ich will ins Haus.
Lass mich ins Haus.
Lass mich ins Haus, die Leute bei mir spawnen.
Oh, wir haben B gelegt.
Oh, nice.
Massive.
Ich seh nix.
Könnt ihr sterben, please?
Die diffusen gerade.
Wo ist der, wo...
Alter, wo ist der Dude?
Check mal, ob ich wo der ist.
Okay, easy clap, easy clap.
Oh, da war einer.
Der denkt jetzt, Achtung.
Das war das Massive Mind Games.
Der denkt jetzt, ich geh links rum.
Und jetzt, und jetzt, jebait.
Je, je, je, jebaited.
Oh, oh.
Wo ist der Pen?
Wo ist der Penzman?
Der ist einfach weg.
Der Panzer ist einfach abgehauen.
Da hatte ich gesagt, ne?
Jebaited.
Gibt's nicht mehr.
Achtung.
YOLO, YOLO.
Jawoll, jawoll.
Okay, jetzt können wir.
Links ist irgendwas, Leute.
Links ist...
Definitiv.
Hier muss der Peak Action machen wie ein CS, Alter.
Was ist denn hier gerade los?
Ist doch nicht normal.
Ist doch nicht normal, Alter.
What the hell?
Ist das...
Ist das noch Battlefield 3, was wir hier gerade spielen?
Oder ist das schon das neue CS?
Okay.
Liegt hier ne Box?
Hier liegt ne Box.
Eine exzellente Box.
Okay, ich push mal mit dem Tank.
Es bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig, wo es war nicht.
Okay, außer der Tank verpisst sich.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, Tankerino.
So geht das nicht.
So funktioniert das nicht, Tank.
Tank, Mann.
Den retz ich nicht.
Den kann ich nicht retzen.
Links, links, links, links, links.
Alter, ich verstehe gar nicht von wo.
Hey, Max.
Hallo, Kiesauer.
Ne, Kies, Kies, Kieskauer.
Okay.
Die Base ist auch brutal.
Die Base ist richtig hart.
Ohne Panzer kommst du hier nicht durch.
Du brauchst den Big Brain Pantsman, dass das hier funktioniert.
Exzellent, Pantsman.
Guckt euch an.
Gestern hatte ich einen mit nem Trigger-Makro am Start im Game.
Der hat 1,94 mit No-Recall-Trigger-Makro gespielt.
Das war auch geil.
Du hast irgendwo deinen Kopf rausgeschreckt.
Tot.
Pfff.
Inzendown.
Alter.
Die wollen es aber wissen.
Die wollen...
Die sind...
Die sind heiß.
Die sind echt heiß.
Die sind...
Die sind ganz scharf auf uns, ey.
Wir sollten versuchen rechts zu pushen.
Wir sollten versuchen andere Seite durch zu pushen, irgendwie.
Das wird nix.
Also du brauchst hier nen guten Panzer-Man.
Wenn du keinen Panzer-Man hast, wird das nix.
Oh, oh, oh.
Huge.
Huge Push.
Ich seh, ich seh da drüben übrigens nix.
Okay, Vettel, ich versuch dich mal.
What?
Alter, die AS Wall macht Damage.
Vettel, da ist er.
Mach ein Blood.
Jawoll.
In your face, Alter.
Und Reds.
Da ist noch einer.
Hinter.
Monka.
Es...
Die sind so scharf, die Gegner, Alter.
Die sind so scharf.
Die sind richtig scharf, die Gegner.
Die sind ganz, ganz scharf, ey.
Hyper-scharf sind die.
Da muss ich mal...
Da muss der hier...
Du musst hier die...
Sieht wie ein Griecher Man machen.
Okay.
Okay, Vettel, ich hab dich, hab ich, hab ich...
Fuck, NA Aimed.
Ich muss runter.
NA Aimed, krass, NA Aimed, hab ich den.
Hier ist nix mehr.
Oh, da rechts, Alter.
Da gehen wir jetzt rein.
Nein!
Oh, das wär der Ultikill des Jahrtausends geworden.
Das wär der Ultikill des Jahrtausends geworden.
Multikill des Jahrtausends geworden, ey.
Oh. Habt ihr gesehen,
wie sie alle auf einer Linie gestanden haben?
Ich meine, es waren jetzt schon drei mit einem halben
Magazin. Aber den
Bam-Bam-Bam hätt's da richtig Schläge
gegeben.
Der Multikill des Jahrhunderts hätt's da gegeben.
Hauen wir da erstmal
eine Nade rein.
Die Gegner sind echt nicht schlecht.
Oh, nice, nice. Huge.
Massive Nade.
16 Monats.
Ich kann gerade keine Emotes drücken, aber...
Oh, Mist. Ich wollte eine Emote drücken.
Dankeschön für die Subs.
Okay, Leute. Ey, die Gegner sind echt
nicht dumm. Die sind wirklich nicht dumm.
Rätel, ich aim ab vorne.
Oh,
nein, nein, nein.
Kann ich jetzt Big Brain Flank machen?
Geht jetzt Big Brain Flank?
Nice. Ah, der Panzer.
Der Panzerman ist da. Achtung.
Ach, das konnte man ja gar nicht
kaputt schießen, ne?
Ja, ja, Panzer, bleib stehen. Panzer, nein.
Alter, die kriegen offensiv.
Zack, die kriegen offensiv. Zack, in your face.
Panzer, ich kann nicht
weiter runter.
Oh, Massive Smoke.
Big Brain Smoke.
Jetzt will er es.
Jetzt will er es wissen.
Jetzt macht er ernst. Jetzt macht er ernst, der Panzerfahrer.
Vorher hatte er einfach nur Chewbait.
Jetzt holt er den Smoke raus. Jetzt macht er ernst.
Das Dumme ist nur,
mit dem Smoke sehe ich halt auch nichts.
Okay, okay. Easy.
Easy win. Easy win, Leute.
Trübend stirbt alles.
Aber, oh, guck mal, es ist nur noch ein M, komm.
Nur noch ein M, komm.
Links spawnt was, rechts spawnt.
Au.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ah.
Aber gute Runde.
Gute Runde. Egal, ob wir gewinnen oder verlieren.
Nice, nice, nice. Oh, Fatal Fatal.
Spawn, spawn, spawn. Nein, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben.
Nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben.
Jawoll, excellent, excellent. Exquisite.
Jawoll.
Jawoll. Sehr gut.
Nice, Jungs, nice. Habt ihr gut gemacht.
Sehr schön, so muss das sein.
Endlich, endlich mal ein bisschen hier
Intensrunden.
Auch mal ein paar Gegner, auch mal ein paar Gegner,
die was taugen.
Buitwurst.
Bester Name.
Und ihr wisst ja,
ihr wisst ja, Leute,
wenn man gewonnen hat,
egal wie knapp,
und es war ja knapp,
ihr wisst, es ist immer,
also, wenn man gewinnt, egal wie knapp,
es ist immer, immer GG Eats.
So, gut, dass wir das geklärt haben.
Und heck, wenn der Gegner gewinnt.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte gestern echt einen Typ am Start,
der hatte ich
across the map
dauerfeuert
AN-94 in den Kopf.
Also, ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass er ein Aimbot hat.
Ich glaube, der hat an sich ganz gut geaimt.
Der hatte einfach
ultra krasses No-Recall-Trigger-Machung.
Und für die AN-94, ey.
Oh je.
Oh, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's anstrengend, Leute.
Passt mal auf.
Passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Also, High-IQ-Play reicht
für die ganze Sache jetzt schon gar nicht mehr.
Was wir jetzt gleich machen.
Wir machen jetzt Monka-Giga-IQ-Play.
Zeig euch das mal.
Die Gegner müssen aber mitmachen.
Okay.
Fuck, warum...
Okay, okay, okay. Achtung, Achtung, huge.
Nein, nein, nein, fuck.
Ich bin zu spät.
Normalerweise ist das echt...
Oh, das ist das beste Play.
Wenn du ungefähr mit dem Timing zur Seite an den Felsen läufst.
Venice Unleashed-Stream.
Ja, ja, ja.
Definitiv Venice Unleashed-Stream.
Jetzt werden die Mörser rausgeholt.
Ich merke schon...
Oh, die drücken gut, die drücken gut, die Gegner.
Monak-S.
Aber ich sag euch, diese Posi an dem Felsen,
wenn du da mit dem richtigen Timing nehmen reinläufst,
bam, bam, bam,
dann ist...
Okay, wo ist der Typ?
Oh, der ist noch auf dem Spielplatz.
Wir müssen weg, wir müssen weg, wir müssen weg.
Sag mal, was ist hier mit den Gegnern gerade los?
Guckt euch das mal vor.
Vor die Abdeckung gehen.
Ich wollte Big Brain Flank machen
und ich dachte mir, die aimen links eh ab.
Jetzt müssen wir...
Oh, shit.
Okay, das war's.
Jetzt ist A auch weg.
Metro ist so ein Ding, ne?
Metro, die erste Base.
Die kann extremst schwer sein zu kriegen.
Oder du hast den Instant.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, what?
Sag mal, wo sind die denn immer?
SSF ist das Solo-Self-Found-League.
Ja, Metro-Supporter.
Also, du kannst hier übelst reinsprayen.
Also, die Gegner drücken wirklich krass.
Das ist jetzt nicht...
Das ist nicht so, dass das irgendwelche Kank-Noob-Gegner sind.
Die sind nicht ohne.
Der Typ ist hier hinter der Mauer, ne?
Das ist klar.
What the fuck?
Oh, Diffuse...
Diffuse Man.
Kannst du voll vergessen, ey.
Ich würde dich retzen, aber ich komme nicht raus.
Die treffen richtig was.
So.
Jetzt die große Preisfrage.
Wo gehen wir hin?
Okay.
Wir machen den Frontalangriff, wie es aussieht.
Aber das mag ich nicht.
Das mag ich nicht.
Das mag ich gar nicht.
Ich mache mal erstmal eine Flank-Action.
Die sind bestimmt schon da, die Jungs.
Ah, N8, N8.
Und gegen die P90.
Ich dachte nicht, dass die schon hier an der Ecke stehen.
Die machen das auch geschickt mit Smoke.
Da sieht man mal, das bringt richtig was.
Oh, fuck.
Falsche Richtung.
Come on.
Okay, irgendwo in der Ecke hier ist schon noch was.
Die sind echt aggressiv, die Gegner.
Und es sind keine Noob-Gegner.
Was ist denn hier los?
Gleich Serverwechsel danach.
Easy, easy.
Einfach dodgen.
Einfach Gegner dodgen.
Gutes.
Fuck.
Alter, was willst du hier machen?
Die sind wirklich krass drauf, die Jungs, ey.
Also, die sind wirklich hart drauf.
Die Gegners.
Okay.
Also, mehr konnte ich jetzt gerade nicht killen.
Das ging nicht.
Die...
Die drücken auch voll.
Okay, die Base ist auch schwierig.
Wenn wir uns nicht gar so doof anstellen, ist die Base haltbar.
Solange wir es nicht instant verlieren, bevor die Leute reingespawnt sind.
Und nicht gleich rauspushen wie die letzten Deppen.
Ich bleib mal ein bisschen defensiv und mach das Zeug hier wegmachen.
Ich krieg die alle nicht tot.
Das sind zu viele.
Das sind zu viele, Alter.
Fuck.
Die...
Die pushen...
Die pushen viel zu krass durch, ey.
Die kriegste...
Die musst du einmal komplett wegsprayen.
Dass die erstmal ein bisschen in den Stocken kommen.
Das sind aktuell viel zu viele auf einmal.
Der lebt wieder.
Okay, also mehr reinsprayen geht nicht.
Mehr reinsprayen geht gerade echt nicht.
Fuck, von hinten.
Shit.
Wie kommt der da hin?
Alter, Mann.
Die sind echt hart drauf.
Aber...
Aber noch...
Shit.
Buidwurst.
Der Typ irritiert mich.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wir müssen mal links gucken.
Oh, links.
Der Typ ist auf.
Fuck.
Die sind...
Naden wir das mal voll.
Hier ist noch...
Noch nix da.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Kommst du raus?
Oh, nee.
Alter, du...
Ich kann doch nur in eine Richtung gucken.
Vergiss es.
Was soll ich denn machen, ey?
Guck dir das mal an.
Die nehmen uns so übertrieben auseinander.
Alter.
Ist mir unten...
Ist mir in die Ecke durchs Bild gelaufen.
Okay.
Naja, gut.
Da machst nix.
Oh.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Nein.
Muni mal.
Just defuse.
Five head.
Das ist nicht four head.
Das ist mindestens five head.
Ich würde schon fast sagen eleven head.
Das ist...
Das ist genauso wie just win.
Das ist auch so eine kleine Aussage.
Und...
Und Chat.
Ihr wisst ja.
Ihr wisst,
also eine Sache,
wo man in Overwatch-Channels
übelst geil die Leute triggern kann,
ist, wenn du schreibst,
äh,
don't write in chat
if you are not high elo gold plus.
Das ist der...
Die Troll-Kopie passt da schlechthin.
Da reagieren alle drauf.
Only high elo messages.
Gold plus.
Fuck.
Ich dachte, ich krieg den hier geaimt.
Only high elo messages.
Das bedeutet in Battlefield 3
alle die M16 und M14,
die M16 spielen dürfen nicht...
dürfen nicht posten.
Ich natürlich ausgenommen,
weil ich meine,
mich kann ja keiner dran hindern.
Gucken, ob die Nade was...
was reißt.
Trifft eins ganz gut in Gang.
Okay, die sind garantiert hier noch am Start, Jungs.
Hallo, Battlefield.
Lebt der Dude noch?
Lebt der noch da hinten?
Ich mein, hier lebt der noch?
Nein!
Okay, ich muss weg, Leute.
Die kommen jetzt hier.
Wurde der wiederbelebt oder zockt der einfach nur so?
Man weiß es nicht.
Oh, scheiße.
Okay, mehr geht echt nicht.
Mehr geht echt nicht, Rainer.
Wow, wow.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Keck, weh.
He, he, he, he, he, he, he.
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck, Monka?
X.
Giga.
Triple, triple X.
Ich komm mir echt vor wie ein CS hier,
wie du um die Ecke laufen musst.
M320 Flashbang.
Oh ja, das wär nice hier.
Guck mal, der teabaggt mich.
Hat er mich gerade...
Leute, Leute, hab ich mich da jetzt verguckt?
Hat er mich gerade geteabagged?
Keck, quadruple U. Hat er mich teabagged?
Hat er mich teabagged?
Anzeige ist raus.
Ich ruf jetzt direkt in DICE Stockholm an.
What the fuck?
Ich ruf jetzt direkt in Stockholm an, bei DICE,
dass du wirst gebannt. Easy.
Okay, okay, geht nicht.
Gehen wir mal hier rein.
Ja, erschreck mich halt mehr, please!
G18, G18, 0, OP, kacke.
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit. Alle uns alle weggesprayt.
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit. Alle uns alle weggesprayt.
Musste sein, wenn man in der Lobby ist. Ja, stört mich nicht.
POG, POG teabag.
Please more.
More teabag, plitz.
Buidwurst!
Ich find den Namen irgendwie übertrieben geil. Achtung.
G18, G18, stellts.
Hehehehe.
Wow, wow, wow, wow. Alter, Alter, piss dich.
Okay, geht nix.
Ah, geht nix.
Mein Vater arbeitet bei EA, der bannt dich.
Mein Vater arbeitet bei EA, der bannt dich. Was?
Nur bei EA?
Mutter bei Microsoft, Vater bei EA, Onkel bei Ubisoft?
Bruder bei DICE?
Ich hab die ganze Familie verteilt, die wird überall gebannt.
Alles, alles weggebannt.
Oma bei Punkbuster.
Opa bei Wack.
Wobei das ja schwachsinnig ist, weil das nicht die Hersteller sind.
Aber gut.
Ey, es ist nicht normal,
die Gegner. Aber wir halten doch
ganz gut dagegen, oder?
Der Opa bei
Steam.
Opa hat Steam programmiert.
Nice, wir werden eingenebelt.
Excellent.
Ich schieß, ich schieß einfach nur auf
Marker jetzt.
Ich schieß jetzt einfach nur auf Marker.
Hier ist irgendwo was. Passt auf.
Ich sag euch, der sitzt noch an der Ecke, der Dude.
Okay, jetzt.
Pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull.
Nein!
Okay.
Bei der Base läuft es erstaunlich gut.
Aber ich komm nicht mehr aus dem Spawn raus, das suckt.
Wahrscheinlich spawn rapen sie uns einfach
nur jetzt, just for fun.
Oh Mist, fatal, fuck.
Aber
Buidwurst hat gute...
Wann kommt der um die Ecke, der Dude?
Wann kommt denn der Dude hier um die Ecke?
Wo ist er?
Ich seh nix mehr.
Please.
Da ist er.
Ich, Leute, ich bleib jetzt einfach hier.
Ich bleib jetzt einfach hier hinter crouched.
Ich bleib jetzt hier einfach crouched die ganze Zeit.
Einfach crouched hier in der Ecke.
Ah! Im Bus!
Im Bus!
Der Busman.
Okay, vielleicht gewinnen wir die Runde.
Man.
Wir müssen den Busman bashen.
What the fuck?
Ins in den Kopf.
Meine Güte.
Jetzt könnten sie eigentlich Legehände machen.
Oh, nice.
Oh, ich...
Ich helfe unserem Dude.
Ach, wir haben schon defused.
Okay, das war dumm.
Das war dumm.
Das war richtig...
Ich dachte, wir haben noch nicht defused.
Hätte ich die lieber mal davon abgehalten,
zu planten.
Okay, das war's, Leute. Vorbei.
Hände hoch, wir haben verloren.
Hände hoch.
Ich ergeb mich.
Zu viel.
Zu viel auf einmal.
GG Eats.
Immer GG Eats.
Easy mit Hacks, würde ich sagen.
Hätten wir einen Hacker, hätten wir auch gewonnen.
F, ja.
Alles Hacks. Sag ich doch.
Was sonst?
Alles Hacks.
Die letzte M-Core war echt anstrengend.
So, dürfen wir jetzt noch mal attacken?
Gegen das Team Metro attacken, stelle ich mir sehr anstrengend vor.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt volle Pulle
Attack-Action machen.
Linksrum.
An der Mauer.
Ich geh jetzt linksrum an A, an die Mauer.
Community-Game. Ja, du kannst joinen.
What? Da ist nix gestorben!
Lol.
By the way, habt ihr meinen Tribade mitgekriegt mit links an die Mauer?
Ich hab gesagt, falls irgendwie einer
irgendwie einer guckt
im Stream
und dann sage ich einfach
ich geh links,
obwohl ich gar nicht links gehe.
Ha? Ha? Meta-Tribade.
Alter Falder, ey.
Der Chat, was ist eigentlich im Chat schon wieder los?
Hackermans.
Naja, Fatal, Fatal.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Hier ist nice, nice, nice.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Da oben ist irgendein Dude.
Oh, Fatal, ich will nicht.
Ich wollte, ich komm da nicht hin, sonst würd ich dich retzen.
Okay, okay.
Let's go. Easy.
Der weiß, dass ich rumkomme.
Ah!
Guck mal, da bin ich mit der T-Bagged.
PogCamp
Tribaded. Habt ihr gesehen?
Mein Big-Brain-Announcement. Ich hab gesagt, ich geh links
lang im M kommen. Alle geilen sind links an B,
an A.
Und was macht da Max? Der läuft einfach zu B.
Tribaded.
Ich komm mir hier grad echt vor wie ein
CS, ne? Bist ja am
Ecken abcampen extrem.
Ist Suppression immer noch OP?
Ja, gut halt. Das ist halt
Kernbestandteil in dem Game.
Ne, die Taschenlampe nicht. Die Taschenlampe
spielt niemand.
Die sterben. Perfekt.
Die Taschenlampe spielt niemand.
Taschenlampe suckt.
Wir können da nicht so ran stürmen.
Ich komm grad nicht vorwärts.
Ehehehehe.
Äh.
Die unused Voice Lines.
Oh ja, das wär Pog.
Pickover!
Oh fuck, ich bin voll direkt.
Mein Lieblings Voice Line ist ja immer noch
I get
fucked in the ass over here.
Beste Voice Line.
Help, I get fucked in the ass over here.
Ey, der
CS-Up-Aim-Champ is strong.
Was soll ich denn machen?
Ich kann nicht vorwärts.
Sobald ich vorwärts geh...
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, Smoke.
Smoke Reno.
Wallbang, Wallbang Nate. Achtung.
Wallbang Nate. Poggers, Poggers.
Jaaaa.
Wir müssen da einmal richtig, richtig
pushen.
Richtig massive push machen müssen wir.
Einen massiven Push vollführen.
Ahhhh.
Alter, Leute.
Was ist denn hier los?
Ich verpiss mich wieder.
Das ist zu viel.
Oh shit, jetzt kommen sie mit der Shotgun um die Ecke.
No homo vergessen.
Immer no homo dabei.
Das war ja mal ne Zeit lang, so wie man heute
Digger sagt, hat man früher immer irgendwas gesagt.
Was ist denn no homo?
So ey, du spielst aber gut no homo.
What?
Oh, jetzt geht der Scheiß los.
Ihr krasser
Spawnrape, no homo.
Davon Spawnrape überhaupt noch sagen?
Ich meine in Zeiten, wo Blind
Playthrough gebannt wird, da darf man bestimmt
Spawnrape nicht mehr sagen.
Bestimmt Toss.
Das ist bestimmt so krass gegen Toss, das Wort Spawnrape
zu verwenden.
Es ist ja auch ein bescheuertes Wort, ne?
Irgendwo hinterm Baum.
Irgendwo hinterm Baum war er.
Alter.
Der
Zombie Train, ja.
No offense
ist auch geil.
Alter, du dummer Kackspast.
No offense und no homo.
Moment, war da gerade ein Gegner?
Sag mal, bin ich blind oder war da unten ein Gegner?
Krass.
Guckt sie euch an.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nein.
Jetzt hätten wir draufpushen müssen.
Jetzt, wo wir sie gerade.
Oh, Legehände, Legehände.
No homo, Legehände.
Hahaha, I get fucked in the ass over
hier, würde ich sagen.
Help, I get fucked in the ass over.
Aber richtig in die Ass
hat er gerade gekriegt.
Wie viel Uhr, wenn die es unleashed?
Nope.
Eigentlich eine coole Runde, nehmen wir mal auf.
F10?
Lol, da liegt er.
Wie, du knifest den nicht?
Nee, da habe ich keine Reactions mehr im Battlefield.
Nee, da habe ich keine.
Da habe ich keine Reactions mehr für.
Kein Muscle Memory, wie man so schön sagt.
Du Sack.
Ihr seid eindeutig das bessere Team, ihr gewinnt das easy.
Ich würde dich ja eigentlich retten.
Okay, Yolo retts, Yolo retts.
Wurst, Wurst.
Es war es wert, es war es wert.
Easy, easy win.
Jawoll, retts RP farmen.
Nicht RP, ihr wisst was ich meine.
Retts Punkte farmen.
Retts Punkte.
Oh, ich habe nicht mehr viel.
Oh, oh, oh.
Kommst du raus?
Bam, bam, bam.
Ich habe ein Problem.
Sag mal, ist da oben einer drauf?
Alter, die Runde ist so krass, ey.
Was ist mit denen allen los?
Die spielen hier voll um ihr Leben.
Ist das, ist das, ist das Black Ops
Skill-Based Matchmaking oder was?
Haben die sich jetzt gedacht,
okay, wir machen in Battlefield nichts mehr,
aber Skill-Based Matchmaking bauen wir ein.
Du kommst dir ja
fast wie im Ranked vor.
Definitiv nicht normal.
Ich mache die retts RPs
hier.
Easy retts, easy retts.
Easy life.
Nein!
Wo kommt denn der Dude her?
Skill-Based Matchmaking, neun Jahre altes Game
eingebaut, ja easy.
Die machen mich,
die Gegner sind so übertrieben aggressive
drauf, normalerweise
normalerweise pushen Gegner überhaupt nicht
in mich rein in dem Game.
Ich meine, die machen das schon
richtig, aber
ist nicht normal, ist nicht normal.
What?
Alter, also der hat mich eben echt krass
verarscht, oder? Weil der ist ja einfach nur
durchs Bild gehüpft.
Der ist da hochgeflogen, hochgesprungen.
Ich komm vor.
Hol dich.
Die retts RPs werden gefarmt, Leute.
Sag ich.
Da war jetzt nicht klar, von wo oder was
kommt. Aber die Base halt. Das Problem ist,
das Gegner-Team ist ein Ticken besser und
die Base ist
wirklich brutal.
Wallbang, wallbang.
Jetzt kommen sie mit der Shotgun.
OKS.
Ey, hier ist es nicht normal.
Es ist definitiv
nicht normal, was hier abgeht.
Ich komm hier echt falsch. Spiel ich CS?
Oder sowas in der Richtung.
Du bist hier nur am
Ecken abamen.
Du bist echt nur am Ecken abamen.
Komm her, komm her.
Oh, fuck.
Mate.
Ich zähl. Die Gegner.
OK.
Eine Chance haben wir noch.
Nein, ich kann nicht spawnen.
OK.
GG.
Too easy, too easy.
Die Venice Unleashed, Leute.
Übrigens sagen sie immer noch Venice.
Es heißt Venice.
Oder um genau zu sein, heißt das
eigentlich
Venice Unleashed.
Ich glaub, die üben schon
für morgen. Die sind grad im Game
alle.
Venice Unleashed.
You need to unlock
the grenade launcher
or the smoke grenades.
I don't know anymore.
But
I can look next round.
I think you need to make
30 kills with the
grenade launcher.
Ja. I don't know.
Einer streamt gerade.
You need to go.
I think you need to equip
an under rail launcher.
I don't know anymore.
No idea.
Oh, was hab ich denn da jetzt
für ein Kack.
Alter, gehste weg.
Alter, warum spawnen die denn nicht?
WTF?
In your face.
Tja, ich bin nicht gespawnt,
weil ich nach... Das war G-Bait,
dass der mich gefragt hat nach dem
Granatwerfer. Ich sag's euch.
Sonst hätte ich jetzt hier defenden können.
Leute, ihr kommt hier nicht raus.
Sag ich euch. Easy. Easy win.
Passt auf.
Oh nein.
Ich wollte ihn messern.
Ich wollte ihn messern und es ging nicht.
Der saures Meister.
Okay, weißt du was wir jetzt machen?
Ich mach jetzt den Pogflank.
Den Pogflank auf du.
Hallo? Nope.
Oh, das war nicht der Pogflank.
Aber fast.
Es war on the way to the Pogflank.
Passt mal auf hier.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, das ist keine gute Idee.
MP5.
Mach mal 360.
Nö, warum?
Wozu soll ich jetzt einfach geradeaus laufen
und mich im Kreis drehen, oder wie?
Ja. Easy.
Oh nein, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Ich sag es euch.
Wir müssen jetzt darüber durchballern.
Oh nein, nein, nein.
Und immer schön spotten in Smoke.
Immer schön in Smoke spotten.
Jetzt haben sie es.
Und ich bin nicht gespawnt am Anfang.
Das war, weil ich das zeigen musste.
Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog.
Wallbang Nate.
Okay, keiner mehr da, keiner mehr da.
Wir müssen da rüber gucken.
Da drüben darf nichts lang, ey.
Wie sie da durchtreffen?
Okay Leute, ich geh mal kurz auf die andere Seite,
das abchecken.
Ich hab da so meine Bedenken.
Da ist ein Dude von uns.
Bleert, bleert.
Wow, AEK, bam.
Nochmal, nochmal Rats.
Ich komm noch ein Stückchen zurück, komm noch ein Stückchen zurück.
Please, please, please.
Come on, come on, come on.
Excellent, excellent.
Oh ne, jetzt sind sie drüben, fuck.
Ich muss auch gucken, wenn die hier rauskommen.
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Fuck, Scheiße, das war's jetzt.
Jetzt vorbei.
Battlefield 4 kam viel zu früh.
Ja, seh ich auch so.
Seh ich ganz genau so.
Wie gesagt, Battlefield 3 ist so ein Service-Game.
Drei, zwei, ein.
Excellent.
Wir halten das erstaunlich gut, Leute.
Wisst ihr das?
Ich kann dich da nicht retzen.
Das ist...
voll in the line here of fire.
Oh, oh, jetzt kommen sie von links.
Ey, ich blick hier grad
absolut nicht mehr durch.
Von wo?
Woher wissen die Dudes überhaupt,
wo ich rumstehe?
Guckt euch mal an. The fuck?
Boah.
Jetzt haben sie es, jetzt haben sie es.
Alter, was ein Gespenst.
Das Gespämme.
Das Gespämme, ey.
Guck mal, ich hab kaum Kills gemacht,
nur drei Spillionen Assists.
Da schimmeln sie, schimmeln sie an B rum.
Der läuft wieder da rum.
Ja, aber was willst du sonst machen?
Okay, komm, wir machen Objective-Mode.
Wir machen Objective, wir gehen
Anti-Tank, Anti-Tank.
GG Eats.
Guckt euch den Chat an, ey.
Guckt euch den Chat an.
GG Eats
my ass, ey.
Ist der Panzer schon gespawnt?
Jetzt spawnt der Panzer.
Pantsman kommt. Achtung.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, wo der Panzer
genau ist. Irgendwo da.
Wo ist der Panzer? Steht der noch im Weg?
Ich versuch den Panzer
zu killen.
Ja, auf Panzer.
Jetzt traut sich der Panzer nicht. Ich fass es nicht.
Sonst, oh jetzt.
Ey, die drücken
krass rein.
Ich muss die an dieser Stelle in den Gang halten.
Sonst geht da erstmal nix.
Okay, ich bleib mal.
Wir machen Objective-Mode.
Objective-Mode.
Oh bam, habt ihr gesehen?
Habt ihr die Rakete gesehen, wie nice die getroffen hat?
Across-Map.
Fuck.
BR, also Firestorm war das beste an Battlefield.
Hab ich jetzt schon von einigen gehört?
Ich hab's nie ausprobiert.
Okay, ich muss killen, ich muss killen.
Wenn ich nix kill, suckt.
Ich kann nicht Objective machen.
Shit, Alter.
Ach fuck, das ist ja gar keine Tür.
Von hinten, oder?
Ja, na klar.
Okay, ich muss, ich muss auf.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall Sturmsoldaten bleiben.
Leute, wusstet ihr, dass ich dachte,
am Anfang Medics halten mehr aus als der Rest?
Äh, nicht Medics, ähm, Supporter.
Man kann ja aufs Dach.
Ich dachte am Anfang Supporter
halten mehr aus als der Rest.
Weiß nicht so genau, warum.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die so gepanzert aussehen.
Gar nicht so, ist totaler Schwachsinn.
Moment, wir haben beides, wir haben,
wir haben beides entschärft bekommen?
Oh nein.
What? Alter, ich war ja mal
so um die Eck.
Achtung, YOLO-Modus, YOLO-Modus
activated.
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh,
der Panzmann, der Panzmann.
Oh, wir haben den Panzer geklaut, nice.
Wir brauchen was zum retten.
Fuck.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir auf andere Seite gucken.
Okay, ich geh zu B.
Oh, oh, ich muss da rauf, ich muss da rauf, ich muss da rauf,
ich muss da rauf.
Kommt her, kommt her.
Nice. Ich mach die Runde nur Assists,
ne?
Assists, Assists, Gameplay only.
Guckt euch mal an,
die Punkte, nur von Assists.
Okay, okay, Achtung,
YOLO-Modus.
Nee, ich kann hier nicht weg, sobald ich hier weggehe,
sobald ich hier weggehe,
ist RIP. Ich will hier eigentlich flanken.
Nice.
Oh, da kommt der Panzmann.
Fuck.
Okay, jetzt sind sie, jetzt sind sie ran.
Nice, so Flank-Action hat aber nichts gebracht.
Jetzt haben sie.
Jetzt haben sie es da.
Gucken, vielleicht kriegen wir den Panzer down.
Hit.
Ja, ja. Jawoll!
Cross the Map.
Wir müssen gucken, dass jetzt, sag mal,
was ist mit dem Panzer los? Warum lässt er sich so easy hitten?
Lol, weh.
Hahaha.
Los, wir gucken, dass hier in der Mitte nichts lang kommt.
RPG on Inf.
Kack, Noob, lol.
RPG on Inf, lol.
Da wirst, da wurdest du immer geflamed für früher.
Hehehehehe.
Okay, ich brauch mal was zum
Nachladen. Da kommt der Panzmann.
Panzmann ist am Start.
Oh, aua, aua, ey.
Stop it.
Ist der Panzer tot? Nee.
Bam. Hit.
Das bringt jetzt auch nichts.
Ich bräuchte mal ne Muni. Liegt irgendwo ne Munikiste?
Hier liegt ne Munikiste, oder?
Nice.
Oh, der hat die, der hat ja die
Massive Big Brain Poggers
Posi aller Zeiten.
Einfach mal einen Smoke sprayen.
Gib mir ne Granate, Alter.
Gib mir ne Granate aus dem Pack.
Ich brauch ne Granate für die zwei Dudes gegenüber.
Achtung, Achtung, die Nate, passt mal auf hier.
Poggers Nate. Und, und, und, bam.
Okay, nix.
Ich seh gar nix mehr.
Ich seh gar nix mehr, okay.
Panzer?
Äh.
Okay, so war das nicht geplant, Leute.
Sag ich euch ehrlich.
RPG oder Inf mir jetzt einen ab.
Ist mir vollkommen egal, ob das Noob ist oder nicht.
Scheiß drauf, juckt mich überhaupt nicht,
ob das Noob ist.
Juckt mich so nicht, ob das Noob ist.
Den Kramer schließlich gewinnen.
Der ist voll reingerannt.
Der ist um die Ecke gekommen
und ich hab die Raketenwerfer in die Fresse gekriegt.
Null weh.
Disabled, jetzt truff.
Jetzt truff, mach die platt.
Fuck, ich hab's probiert.
Ich hab noch ne Rakete gegeben, aber...
Oh nee, der hat hier 30 Milliarden
Rep-Typen am starten, jetzt bin ich tot, das suckt.
Fuck.
Guck mal, Leute, der Max stirbt.
Der Max stirbt.
M kommt verloren, so ist es.
So ist es einfach.
Jetzt hier.
Zeit revealed.
Nice, sehr gut gemacht, Team.
Poggers-Team, Poggers-Team.
Sind da welche durchgepusht?
Oh, ich glaub, da sind welche durchgepusht.
Gibt's hier... Wo ist ne Munibox?
Wo ist ne Munibox? Ich brauch ne Munibox.
Munibox, Munibox.
Oh, andere Seite.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, die sind durchgepusht.
Fa...
Oh.
Ey, da ist in der Mitte einer drin, kann das sein?
Au, au.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob da einer durchgerannt ist.
Nein, fuck.
Rip.
Vielleicht krieg ich nen Rats, wer auf jeden Fall...
Nice, nice, nice.
Poggers, Poggers, Poggers.
Okay, das M-Com haben wir.
Das M-Com ist auch krass hier, das ist auch wirklich schwer.
Der Panzer ist durchgefahren, oder?
Ne.
Oh, in de Fresse.
Die Suppression ist richtig brutal.
Da sitzt er.
Richtung anderem M-Com.
No, scheiß drauf, scheiß drauf.
Wir müssen einfach nur B halten.
Äh, äh,
A meinte ich eigentlich.
Bam.
Der Panzer lässt sich gut hitten.
Oh, Panzer.
Warum halten die Panzer eigentlich so krass viel aus?
Weil ich hab da sonst was
reingehämmert jetzt.
Okay, Panzer ist leer.
Sehe ich das richtig? Die sind auf der Brücke?
Okay, jetzt, jetzt ist, jetzt ist der
jetzt ist die Overwatch-Taktik.
Die pushen jetzt nochmal alle, die pushen jetzt alle nochmal.
Overwatch-Taktik.
Easy win, easy win, Leute.
Wenn wir das einfach
einfach halten, einfach halten.
Boah.
Uh.
Anstrengend, ey.
Echt anstrengend.
GG.
Eats. Eats.
Wir haben gewonnen, also ist es
aus Prinzip.
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Easiest game of my life.
Der Panzer-Guy hat wirklich nix
gerissen. Hey, Bay, da hast du aber recht.
Der Panzer-Typ war wirklich
kacke.
Der Panzer-Typ, der hatte gefühlt
20 Engineers hinter sich.
Oh, der ist nicht schlecht hier.
Aptik hat gar nicht gesehen, weil Chat
eingeblendet ist.
Zeig mal deine Aufträge, please.
Äh, was meinst du hier?
Ich hab kaum was anloggt
auf dem PC.
Ähm.
Wo sind das nochmal?
Signments?
Welche willst du sehen?
Warte, falsche Richtung.
Schlecht.
Hallo, springen, springen.
Uh.
Schreckt, Max, schreckt.
Lass sie bloß nicht retzen, ey.
Äh, was
die nicht retzen.
Jawoll, jetzt, bam.
Jawoll, nice.
Ey, wo sind wir hier?
Hä? Ach, wir sind im Spawn,
alter. Sagt es mal einer.
Pff, okay, da machst du nix.
Nein, nein, nein, linksrum machst du nix.
Das, by the way, willkommen bei
einem der heftigsten M-Comps im ganzen Game.
Hätte ich
jetzt einen Granatwerfer dabei, könnte ich probieren,
da oben das Ding runter
zu ballern.
Kommt die Nate gut?
Der Dao-Typ ist wieder da.
Backblock.
Der Dao-Typ ist, der Shotgun-Man ist wieder da.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Shit.
Ey, das ist
wieder der Wahnsinn.
Warum kommt Vinny's Unleashed? Jop.
Nice. Ich freu mich schon richtig.
Nice, hu, freu du.
Ich mach, ich mach den
Team-Champ up-aim.
Up-aim-Champ.
Der Up-aim-Champ ist am Start.
Ich will nur sicher gehen, dass da keiner kommt
von da.
Jetzt, wo ich nicht hingucke, ne?
Jetzt, wo ich nicht hingucke.
Jetzt seid ihr da.
Ich glaub, ist keiner mehr da.
Ich brauch Granate, ich brauch ne Granate.
Gebt mir ne Granate aus dem Medipack.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine. Ich meine Dings Nachfüllpack.
Gebt mir ne Granate, Alter.
Nachfüllpack, please.
Gebt mir ne Granate.
Jetzt.
So, jetzt mit Schmackes. Und wenn das Ding explodiert...
Bam.
Jawoll.
Knackt.
Denkt dran, hier oben kann keiner respawnen.
Ich sag das einfach nur
zu mir selbst gerade.
Easy.
Easiest M-Com aller Zeiten.
Ja, das bringt euch jetzt auch
nix mehr, Leute, wenn ihr das...
Das ist nochmal reingesprayt.
Next, please.
On a pants man.
Nein!
Alter, warum?
Warum sitzt jetzt irgend so ein Dude drinnen, der nicht mal rappen kann?
Ah, ne, Moment.
Unsere Leute sind im Panzer. Okay, alles gut.
Alles gut, alles gut. Ich hab nix gesagt.
Aber ich mach trotzdem
Repair Champ.
Ich mach Repair Champ.
Repair Champ ist unterwegs.
Bisschen Abwechslung.
Leute, Repair Champ kommt.
Achtung. Nicht sterben.
Schweißbrenner Champ
ist am Start.
Wie gefällt dir eigentlich der Crossbow?
Ich glaub, den hab ich auf dem PC nicht mal unlockt.
Ja.
Reparierungsman.
Lass mich reparieren.
Ich bin der Reparierungsman.
Nein.
Bleib da.
Ich muss mich irgendwo dahinter verstecken.
Der Repairman.
Für das Team.
Hier ist gut.
Hier seh ich was und keiner sieht mich.
Excellent.
Sehr gut.
Lass mich in dein Panzer.
Jawoll.
Teamplay beste.
Und nebenbei noch Bash Champ.
Das müsst ihr erstmal nachmachen.
Oh, da kommt gleich was links.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo der Dude ist.
Hallo.
Schweiß Champ.
Nicht mal dritter Sitzplatz. Doch, die haben eigentlich
dritten Sitzplatz. Eben waren drei drinnen.
High Octane Repair
Gameplay hier.
What?
Kann mir irgendeiner erklären, was das war gerade?
Panzman.
Ah.
Ey, der Panz-Typ ist echt
schwer zu reparieren, ne?
Ich stell's dem jetzt einfach nur hinterher.
Ich muss halt auf der Seite bleiben.
Lass mich die Gegner nicht sehen.
Nein, Panzman. Lass mich nicht allein.
Okay, Panzman, jetzt hast du's verloren.
Hä?
Okay, aber jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ohne Repair-Support-Champ hätten die das nicht gepackt.
High Octane Repair
Gameplay.
Guck mal, aber das bringt ein paar Punkte.
Aber Kills bringen definitiv mehr
Punkte.
So, passt mal auf. RPG und Inf. Lull.
Es wär halt geil,
wenn ich wenigstens gunnern könnte zwischendurch.
Aber gibt's nicht.
Auf Panzer, macht's
platt. Man kriegt übrigens noch nicht mal
Kill-Punkte für den Repair-Champ, ne?
Aha.
Du kommst hier nicht rein, Alter.
Ich hab so viel Repair-Champ gemacht.
Wenn ich jetzt noch treffen würde.
Alter, Kollege,
du kannst mich da mitten reinfahren.
Wie soll ich denn da rappen?
Der Repair-Champ ist on the way hier.
Hinter uns ist ein EOD-Bot, oder?
Repair-Champ,
Repair-Champ.
Okay, ich würd sagen,
ich bin zwar nicht der Erste mit den Punkten,
aber die Runde
war eindeutig carried by Repair-Champ,
oder?
Ohne Repair-Champ wär da nicht viel gegangen.
Wollen wir nicht mal probieren,
den Server mit Viewer zu füllen?
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt,
das ist,
das sind zu 90% Viewer
auf dem Server grad.
MVP Repair-Champ, ja.
GG Eats.
Übrigens, ne Runde kann man noch spielen.
Ich glaub dann,
ach ne, Moment, ist erst 17 Uhr.
Oh ne, vergesst, vergesst.
Hast mit EOD scharf gemacht, nice.
Ja, auch so geile
Dinger. Dieser EOD-Bot, der ist ja
zu 90%
useless. Aber die 10%, woran
was bringt, ist halt POG.
Nochmal Metro, okay. Also.
Metro.
Ja, das sackt auf dem Server, aber Metro
und Bazaar ist halt die, wo die
meiste krass Action abgeht. Nächstes Mal
haben wir einen anderen Server. Wobei, morgen, morgen ist er
eh vorbei, morgen gibt's die Poggers.
Poggers-Server.
Oh, guck mal, ich kann mich schon bewegen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, Leute.
Wir dürfen da nicht zu viel erwarten, ja.
Einmal die AUG benutzen. Ich glaube, ich hab für die AUG
gar nichts freigeschaltet. Ich könnte
die SCAR verwenden, ich könnte die AEK
verwenden, ich könnte, äh...
Oh ne, N8.
NA-aimed, Alter.
NA-aimed.
Alles klar, easy, easy, easy.
Okay, Leute,
wir müssen jetzt... Ah, shit.
Von wo ist denn der Kleist unterwegs?
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich schön reinpushen,
oben in diesen Park.
Also, wenn's bei
Venice Unleashed gute Server gibt, poste ich auf jeden
Fall einen. Könnt ihr euch drauf verlassen.
Poggers-Hosting
mach ich dann. Nein!
Warum?
Warum peakt ihr gleichzeitig?
Klein Pro-Gamer
hier.
Klein Pro-Gamer.
Nein, nein, nein, Vettel nicht retzen.
Wow, war das meine?
Ey, nicht, nebelt mich
nicht ein.
Fuck, der Core-Gamer.
Ey, der Typ,
das ist, das ist der, der mit dem,
mit dem AN-49 Trigger-Skript oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung, der Typ ging gestern auch übelst
krass ab.
Keine Ahnung, ob er ein Trigger-Skript hat, wahrscheinlich nicht mal.
Wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal.
Wahrscheinlich nicht mal, aber ey,
der ist, der geht ab.
Der Core-Gamer, den hatten wir gestern auch schon.
Okay, ich muss mich mal kurz
verpissen hier.
Gucken, was da an A los ist.
Aua.
Es, guckt ihn euch an.
Alter, der Core-Gamer.
Der wollte es gestern schon
so krass wissen.
Was ist da für, was ist da vorne für
ein PEGA-Aimer am Start?
Ach, das geht ja in den
Büschen nicht, habe ich vergessen.
Ey, das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Ich mache nach der, ich glaube, ich mache nach der Runde echt Pause.
Guckt ihn euch an. Ist das normal?
Alter.
Der geht echt ab.
Der Core-Gamer, Mann.
Wie, der ist auch weiß?
Wie gerade das?
Alter.
Okay, ich schaue jetzt ab.
Wir sind ein bisschen, wir sind ein bisschen zu,
zu Spawn-Rate-mäßig unterwegs gerade.
Ey, wenn da ein paar unsinnig
vorne sterben, ist das auch mal schnell vorbei.
Ich bewege mich nicht.
Ja, das ist wohl wahr.
Haben die eine Drohne
am Start irgendwie, die alles spottet?
Alter, ey,
die sind krass drauf gerade wieder.
Obwohl, ich glaube, die machen
eins. Die machen Bash den Streamer
und dafür pushen sie nicht.
Ich stelle es jetzt einfach hier unten rum.
Im 360. Kann mir nichts passieren.
Ey!
Ich stecke meinen Kopf raus und bin
tot, Alter!
Was ist denn jetzt gerade los?
Äh, ja.
Fs-Taske, ich auch.
Die Sache ist nur die,
ich, ich glaube, die sind ein bisschen
Alter.
Ich glaube, die sind ein bisschen spät dran.
Also, ich würde mich gerne eines
Besseren belehren lassen.
Das ist Huge-Stream-Style. Was ist denn hier
los gerade? Ich würde mich wirklich...
Alter! Ich bin...
Ich...
Ich bin da und bin instant down.
Bitte, what the fuck?
Okay, jo.
Was? Origin kostet 39
Euro? Okay, wir gucken gleich
mal auf irgendeiner Keyshop-Seite.
Battlefield ist...
Also, es gibt es auf Twitch gerade kostenlos,
by the way, ne?
Easy, Kriech-Champ.
Kriech-Champ.
Kriech-Champ. Ah, okay.
Alter, Alter, Alter.
Ich glaube, der Default-First
hat an. Kann schon sein.
Die Gegner wollten es gerade
echt wieder wissen, aber die haben halt überhaupt nicht objective
gespielt. Okay, Leute.
Machen wir die Attack-Runde noch? Machen wir die
Attack-Runde Metro noch?
Hallo, ich... Meine Maus ist weg.
Kann ich skippen?
Meine Maus ist einfach weg. Easy.
Easy, Maus weg. GG.
Nawal, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Meine Maus ist weg.
What the fuck? Game, please.
Vielleicht ist die Maus ja nächste Runde
wieder da. Aug. Ich hab
für die Aug nix freigeschaltet.
Für die Aug Ironsides.
Ich muss eh morgen wieder alles...
Alter, meine Maus ist weg!
Okay, ich mein, in-game
braucht man die Maus nicht, aber...
Ah, jetzt ist die Maus wieder da. Easy.
Leute, falsche Richtung.
Das wäre hier mit einem Controller nicht passiert.
Das ist richtig. Okay, wir gehen
jetzt zuerst wieder auf A.
Weil A das, äh...
Entscheidende
hier ist.
Alter, die Suppression. Meine Güte.
By the way, unsere Perks sind kacke.
Ey, die Suppression, die macht mich fertig.
Achtung, YOLO-Racer.
Dreimal Ammo!
Was ist denn das, Leute? Perks, Alter.
Ja, nicht sterben,
nicht sterben, alles klar.
Sterben, overrated, she baited.
Okay, okay, also
ich switch jetzt mal auf... Oh, ne, ich switch nicht.
Au, au, au, au.
Jo, jo, jo, jo.
Ah, shit.
Ey, der Default First ist wirklich krasser.
Krasser Skiller, ey.
Der trifft schon erstaunlich gut.
Aber, ey, ich, ganz ehrlich.
Wär wirklich... Ich glaube nicht, dass
er cheatet. Das wär auch total hängen geblieben.
Letztendlich. Warum sollte er, ja?
Und das kannst du an so ein paar Kleinigkeiten
eh nicht abmachen.
Ähm...
Dazu kommt, wer in so einem alten Game
cheatet, ist wirklich beknackt.
Aber ganz im Ernst.
Okay, jetzt kann ich Perks ändern.
Äh, customize,
load out...
Sprint...
Cover...
Der Dau, man.
Ist der wieder am Start?
Der Dau, man, ist der wieder da?
Der passt auf jeden Fall
gut auf, aber ganz ehrlich, das wird mir
nicht gefallen, das trifft jeder.
Düt, düt, düt.
Der Haihappen, den kenn ich, der ist aus dem Chat.
Moin, Haihappen.
Ey, wisst ihr, was mich das grad wieder dran erinnert?
Wie geil das war.
Als einfach dieses Game angesagt war.
Das war Massive Poggers.
Als das Game
angesagt war, so geil.
Ich konnte einfach Content machen zu einem Game, was ich gerne spiele.
Und hat unendlich
viel zum reden.
Problem ist,
dass mir die neuen Battlefields
nicht mehr gefallen.
Und das Battlefield an sich auch ein bisschen
Flavor of the Month
eingebüßt hat. Battlefield ist ja nicht mehr so angesagt.
Und dazu kommen die neuen Battlefields gefallen mir nicht.
Also was im Endeffekt darauf rausläuft, dass
ja, kannst kein Battlefield machen.
Und YouTube ist auch
ein bisschen was anderes.
Nein, nein.
MonkaS. Beste.
So ist das immer äußerst
nice, wenn man sich gegenseitig
killt.
X Fatal, ich versuch dich zu holen.
Jetzt haben sie, jetzt haben sie alle wieder
angeschaltet, die Gegner.
Die drücken, die fangen jetzt instant
an zu drücken.
Instant Pressure.
Guck sie dir an.
Nice. Poggers.
Boah, ich muss echt Pause machen.
Ich habe hier Reaction
echt wie als wäre ich 36.
Ich stelle euch das mal vor.
Wo kommt man da hin?
Ey, das gibt es nicht.
Kack Game, ne? Kack Game.
Hätte das letztes Mal beim ersten Mal funktioniert,
hätten wir ihn gehabt.
What?
Da macht er die 360's, seht ihr das?
Der Q
E-Q Predator.
Der macht hier die.
Was auch immer das bringen soll.
Aber sieht stylisch aus.
Predator.
Die Predator Schnubbelmaschine.
Ey, manche Sachen vom Krieger
waren echt schon heftig cringe, ne?
Manches war echt schon
massive cringe.
Boah.
Nice. Ey, das hier, kommt es dir vor
wie als Spieler spielst du
CS?
Du musst am Ecken abamen auf Doom, ey.
Oh, falsche
Richtung. Die Base ist aber
echt krass. Leute, ich merke es, ey.
Wie lange bin ich jetzt on? Macht mal einer
please uptime. Die Map ist auch
für 24. Na.
Geht, geht, geht.
24, 32.
Das einzige, was halt nicht geht, ist 64.
64 geht halt nicht.
64 kannst du vergessen.
48 ist auch noch halbwegs
spielbar, aber auch schon nicht mal gut.
Aber 64 ist vorbei.
Das ist übrigens was, was
anderen Battlefields
Battlefields wirklich fehlt. Ordentliche
Line of Sights, die durchdacht sind.
Kleiner Camperman.
Kleiner.
What?
Ich habe gerade mit dem Auge
kurz nach links hingeguckt, wo unser Typ
gestorben ist und inzen downen.
Alter!
Lass mich doch einfach mal aufstehen, please.
Warte, Moment. Wir haben gelegt?
Wir haben gelegt?
Legehänne Deluxe,
Alter.
Legehänne Deluxe hat er gemacht. Habt ihr
das gesehen? Sneaky Legehänne.
Sneaky Legehänne.
Alter,
jetzt wollen sie es wieder wissen.
Ja, ich habe eigentlich gedacht,
während wir hier Action machen, pushen die auf der anderen
Seite rein, aber vergiss es.
Ihr könnt es schon mal aufnehmen, die Runde war eigentlich ganz nice.
Rasiert die Runde.
50-10. Hm.
Vielleicht ist es einfach nur gut.
Oh, wir haben gelegt. Die Legehänne
ist real. Die Legehänne ist real.
Wir müssen da hin, wir müssen da hin, wir müssen da hin, wir müssen da hin, wir müssen da hin,
wir müssen da hin. Wir müssen uns sowas von beeilen. Oh, nee, nee, nee,
die bashen alles schon.
Nein!
No! Paperhands!
Paperhands!
Es war so close.
Oh.
Meine Güte.
Boah.
Mega anstrengend.
Puh.
Wir wollten auch ne Consultierlist machen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt noch
da jetzt noch Brain
Aktivität für habe.
Der Default First, der hat Gaming Socken,
Gaming Stuhl, Gaming Tisch,
Gaming Grip, FPS, Freaks,
G Fuel,
alles hatte der, alles.
Aber Leute,
ultra nice, fast 300 Leute am Start
für Battlefield 3.
Das ist äußerst poggers.
Sehr nice.
Schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid.
By the way, habe ich schon mal gesagt,
dass es aktuell
mit Amazon Prime
kostenlos Battlefield 3 auf Twitch gibt.
Und wenn ihr gerade dabei seid
und euren Amazon Account
eh verbindet mit Twitch, könnt ihr mir auch
gleich einen Prime-Sub dalassen,
wenn euch das ganze gefällt.
Ich meine, das Geld für das Game habt ihr eh gespart.
Big Brain Move.
Sichert euch plus 50 IQ.
Oh.
Ja, es ist witzig, ne?
Wenn ich mal auf Twitch gucke.
Battlefield 3.
Also, bei mir
sind irgendwie 90% der Zuschauer 0 W.
Guck mal.
Nachher kommen noch ein paar andere.
Hey, der kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ist der nicht öfters, ist der Typ nicht auch öfters bei
diesem Top-Play-Channel am Start?
Guck mal, bei ihm gibt es sogar einen
BF3-Free-Key.
Den hosten wir gleich. Den hosten wir gleich.
Primordial Nightmare.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Andy Teschi auch. Danke für den Sub.
Und sorry an alle, die ich vielleicht
übersehen habe, während ich hier am Start
war in-Game. Ich guck mal kurz.
Ähm.
Der Eichler, 16 Monate. Dankeschön.
Gar nicht gesehen, ja.
Na, wahl hatte ich?
Sorry, falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Martin hat abonniert für 14 Monate.
Jupp.
Also, nice, dass ihr alle am Start gewesen seid, Leute.
Massive.
Äh, nee, nee.
Ich würde sagen,
wir hosten den jetzt mal. Oh, Major.
Nee, nicht Major.
Mature Audience. Wir hosten ihn jetzt mal hier.
Easy. Easy Host, Easy Live.
Nee, Raid. Wir raiden.
Ja, wir raiden.
Raid. Zack.
Äh, hallo?
Wie pasten? Dann muss ich es schreiben.
T-C-O-T-C
Bounty.
Alles klar, ich kenn den Stream nicht, aber andere
Battlefield-Leute muss man, muss man
supporten. Ähm.
Dieser Kanal richtet sich an Erwachsene.
Also, Leute. Benehmt euch. Benehmt euch.
Also.
Leute, wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut. Bis denn.
See you.